ein leben unter der erde seit zwei
monaten keine tageslichts kein normales
leben mehr keinen alltag mehr wir
schauen in die zweitgrößte ukrainische
stadt nach haarriss im nordosten dort
1,5 millionen einwohner viele geflüchtet
und dort halten sie sich auf und sie
versuchen gerade den kindern den
kleinsten auch ein paar mal am tag ein
lächeln in die augen zu zaubern dort
unten in der metrostation von takis
warten die menschen auf ein ende des
krieges unser reporter ihren stritzel
war dort
atemberaubende architektur und
kunstvollen verzierungen so sehen sie
aus die metrostationen von kharkiv vor
dem krieg gegen die ukraine 30 stationen
jede ganz eigen auf ihre art etwas ganz
besonderes webseiten widmen sich gar der
kür der schönsten stationen seit
kriegsbeginn hat aber niemand mehr ein
auge für die metro kunst jetzt geht es
ums überleben im untergrund
[Musik]
28 kilometer lebensader der 1,5
millionen einwohner stadt werden zum
zufluchtsort vor den russischen raketen
und damit zum größten zusammenhängenden
bunker konstrukt
familien harren hier aus manche seit dem
ersten kriegstag die großeltern zusammen
mit ihren kindern und den enkeln alle
suchen schutz vor putins bomben versorgt
werden sie von freiwilligen die irgendwo
in der stadt essen kochen und zu den
tausenden menschen in der metro schaffen
aber es kommt darauf an wie man mit
seiner angst
die situation scheint geordnet sie ist
aber alles andere als entspannt es ist
nicht leicht hier zu leben die
bedingungen sind schwierig wir haben
keine duschen oder solche sachen
zwischen all den letzten habseligkeiten
der familien die oft nichts mehr haben
als das was sie um sich und ihre
matratzen auf dem kalten boden sammeln
gibt es aber auch diese momente ein
junger feiert seinen geburtstag er und
die anderen kinder bekommen eine torte
den auftritt ihrer superhelden und noch
viel mehr ein stückchen normalität ein
lächeln sei es auch nur für wenige
augenblicke
wir sind unserer jungs ein trio die
mutig gesund und fröhlich sind und wir
haben beschlossen unseren kindern mit
allem zu helfen was wir tun können wir
können freude und lächeln bringen damit
helfen wir wir verlassen unsere kinder
nicht
die metro dient also als bunker dieser
wiederum wird umfunktioniert zu einem
konzertsaal oder weil die liebe auch in
kriegszeiten stark genug ist zu einem
standesamt
aber am liebsten wäre es den menschen in
kharkiv und der ukraine in ihrem metros
wieder nur das wären ein ganz normales
verkehrsmittel mit nüchternem netzplan
ganz normal und gleichzeitig wunderschön
[Musik]
darüber sprechen wir mit unserem bild
reporter beyond stritzel weiterhin
unterwegs in der ost ukraine größte dich
herzlich an diesem mittwochmorgen ja das
ist eigentlich das schlimmste was wir
uns vorstellen können dass krieg zum
alltag geworden ist zur gewohnheit
geworden ist ganz speziell auch dort in
den u-bahn-schächten was sagen dir die
menschen dort glauben sie dass sie
irgendwann aus dieser alltag aus dieser
art alltag raus kommen da raus aus
dieser schrecklichen situation in der
sie seit über zwei monaten verharren
also die aufnahme ist natürlich da bei
den vier
monaten aus allerdings war gestern
oberleitungsbusse
mitarbeiter
schlüpften mitgeben haben obwohl er
unter anderem darin geschult
durchgang alten sprengkörper
liegengeblieben willst den kanal und
familien und dergleichen das ist
natürlich ein punkt
möglich eine baldige ja wahrscheinlich
überreste von solcher munition über das
ganze land nach weit verstreuten
darstellen ein weiterer punkt in dem
diese kinder geschult wurden war
das nicht spitz geld erhalten soll
spielzeugen vom gruppen von
kinderbüchern und dergleichen und wo
sind wie und warum die sowjetischen
invasoren haben wir sogar gefallen
damals großen gemacht spielsachen
verdient haben müssen und seinen
sprengstoff
daneben
bestimmen
zudem soll das spielzeug zurücklaufen
und
eben jetzt auch pause für die
danke für den moment führen wir haben
ein paar tonprobleme wollen wir uns aber
trotzdem deine bilder deine fotos noch
mal mitbringen das was du uns dort mit
anschauen das was du uns dort
mitgebracht hast aus der ost ukraine
also die fotos von den kindern die im
moment geschult werden denn den gezeigt
wird das ist ein unterschied ist was
waffen sind was dort auf der straße rum
liegt und was spielzeug ist also das
bringt im moment dieser so bittere
kriegsalltag dort in der ukraine
den kindern muss beigebracht werden wie
man ja der hilfe land reagiert wie man
erste hilfe leistet und wie man waffen
von spielzeug unterscheidet es ist jetzt
alltag gewordene für die kinder im krieg
dort baske aufzuziehen falls irgend
etwas schlimmeres passieren sollte dort
im u bahn zug zu stehen der jetzt gerade
ihr neues zuhause geworden ist dass es
ihr alltag so waren sie dort jeden tag
auf hinten im hintergrund sieht man dich
wie ein stritzel unseren reporter du
hast mit den kindern dort gesprochen die
der berichtet haben über diesen
kriegsalltag vielen herzlichen dank dir
für diese eindrücklichen bilder